si tout à l'heure nous évoquions les
méthodes pour endiguer la violence à
l'école nous avons vu cet exemple à
brive où l'on a réinstauré usage des
bons points
les parents doivent être les premiers
partenaires de l'éducation nationale
pour retrouver le calme dans les
établissements scolaires et certains
évoquent des méthodes beaucoup plus
discutable j'en jouais faut-il interdire
ou non usage de la fessée chez les
enfants la question est débattue il ya
les pourrait y aller contre parmi les
contre le député-maire
d'issy-les-moulineaux andré santini qui
veut faire voter une loi au parlement
contre la fessée la fessée c'est le
thème de notre dossier du jour reportage
de cars lacroix et philippe jarry
la fessée ça arrive dans vos familles
cap faty l'on donne des faits c'est pas
des paroles en train de donner des
fessées
imagine si tu fais une bêtise a fait
trop mal quoi ça fait trop mal c'est
bien de frapper ménage quand même grand
par exemple vers 10 ans parce que vers
la rade par exemple de deux ans et
quatre ans on si par exemple l'enfant
fait une bêtise dans lui dit qu on lui
dit que il recommence plus mais à l'âge
de 10 ans comme il a tout compris qui
recommence la bêtise la hilloula milite
pour que ça parte en deux ans dès que tu
as vu que même un nom images et pendant
donc sinon donc s'il vous faut des idées
étaient de casse l'arrêt d'autres tu vas
du décès porte à pousser peinture par le
monde fait ça au petit fils il s'est
toujours dit qu'une poutre sanctions ça
serait mieux il fait 6 113 500 résout
pas les choses moi c'est bien sûr je me
suis fait mon petit chez moi mon trip de
foot parce qu'on a dit une fois deux
fois trois fois jérémy ne fait pas
jérémy le voilà et quand jérémy va
jusqu'au bout et il fait je ne dis plus
une quatrième fois julie c'était hélas
il comprend aussi
est-ce que tu comprends quand maman elle
met une fessée jérémy une petite fessée
n'est pas une grosse et ses petites
fessées sur les fêtes c'est pas non plus
c'est pas la famille après des fois ils
se une fois qu'on a mis ses deals se
calme je pense pas qu'on soit fier d'eux
mêmes effets scéniques
mais un parent soit fier de mettre une
fessée à son enfant la ccc partie des
petits châtiments corporels au même
titre que la gifle pour beaucoup de
parents elle est l'ultime moyen de poser
les limites
cet espace a été créé il y a deux ans
deux jours par semaine les parents
peuvent-ils dialoguer avec des
psychologues
sous couvert d'anonymat un minicar aux
réponses à leurs questions
la fessée fait partie des sujets
récurrents les parents ne sont jamais
contents d'avoir eu à donner des fessées
effectivement ils culpabilisent et puis
surtout il voudrait savoir et voudrait
arriver à trouver d'autres façons de
faire depuis 20 ans jacqueline corner
réfléchi sur les incidences de la ccl
son expérience de médecin généraliste
sur malakoff lui a permis de tirer des
conclusions inédite qu'elle relate dont
plusieurs ouvrages ainsi plus un enfant
reçoit est fait c'est plus il sera sujet
aux maladies et aux accidents à l'âge
adulte
aujourd'hui à la retraite elle est
entrée en guerre contre la fessée
on dit que c'est les parents laxistes
qui ont des enfants qui vont mal qui
deviennent toxiques au bal délinquants
etc
or il ya c'est une confusion qui est
inacceptable moi je pense que le laxisme
c'est la fessée c'est la seule chose
qu'il ne faut pas éducative
quand donné une claque un enfant tout le
monde sait que ça ne sert à rien tout
est plus difficile que tu fais c'est au
plan éducatif
alors ces deux là il ya un effort à
faire c'est vrai que c'est difficile il
faut faire cet effort le 22 mai 2011
j'attirais l'attention de madame la
ministre déléguée à la famille à
l'enfance sur le problème de l'impunité
trop fréquemment accordée à ceux qui
administrent encore des punitions
corporelles à des enfants et exergue de
la sorte une autorité il
tim sur des mineurs je cite l exemple de
la suède qui depuis 1979 a introduit un
délit de punitions corporelles et je
demandais donc que l'on remette en cause
le droit de punition de fessée infligée
par les parents 22 mai 2000
j'attends encore la réponse andré
santini est le premier à aller aussi
loin
il n'est pas question pour lui d'envoyer
en prison les parents mais il veut créer
une onde de choc pour changer les
réflexes et les mentalités
aujourd'hui la punition est souvent
l'exacerbation d'un énervement du père
ou de la mère d'une peur l'enfant a
failli traversée on lui donne une gifle
non pas pour lui dire ne plus traverser
mais parce que la mère a eu peur et je
crains que le châtiment corporel
aujourd'hui ne soit plus fondées ne soit
plus proportionnés ne soit plus légitime
alors il faut interdire
il faut créer ce délit de punitions
corporelles différait c'est un peu tôt
aujourd'hui que c'est plus une affaire
de culture que de loi franciscain
flamand milite en faveur de la
bientraitance des ans ans mère de quatre
garçons elle n'a jamais eu recours à la
fessée dans les moments difficiles
elle préfère négocier et dialoguer comme
ici avec guilhem son fils aîné pas
qu'elle tombe quand je discute avec un
copain jean copine qui lui a dit c'est
que guy d'amener ses parents ils le
respectent une table jamais et où il
fera bon c'est vrai tout pourtant moi
c'est normal mon père soit je suis une
connerie hop une balance une grosse
paire de claques on puisse mode et des
mains énorme mais pour moi c'est moi
c'est normal et j'étais quand même je te
jeter les phares et négocier ça prend du
temps et le temps c'est la base du
respect on ne peut pas respecter un
enfant quand on n'est pas dans le temps
quand on ne prend pas le temps de faire
les choses
ça veut dire que ça n'est pas impossible
mais c'est une question de choix il faut
renoncer à d'autres choses pour être
dans le temps du respect un temps pour
jouer un temps pour recadrer la facile
pour les parents actifs de concilier
profession et éducation interdire la
fessée comme en suède ou plus récemment
en allemagne
les français ils sont ils prêts ceux qui
ont été fessés sont ils capable
d'éduquer autrement le débat est lancé